chris sale again pitching well last time
out against tampa bay six strong innings
alex core would certainly take that
again and chris is going to feature four
pitches fastball slider and a changeup
fastball at 51 percent slider at 26.6
percent
oh that's a nice start he struck him out
fastball pass to rose arena and one away
now wander franco's switcher to betting
right who had a homer against cursel in
st petersburg and he lifts one of the
air to deep center field with verdugo
going back all the way back to the wall
jumps up off his glove franco around
second on his way to third and he'll
make it in there with a one out triple
wander continues to amaze and not only
with that triple as you get a man in a
scoring position but that is now 36
consecutive games
in which he has reached base runner at
third and one out the two strike pitch
to cruz
throws the ground ball up the middle and
through into center and the rays grab
the lead the bases are loaded for their
best rbi man in austin meadows
and struck him out went with the
fastball so in the end given all that he
strikes out three and they get one run
it's a long single for schwarberg and it
brings up hunter renfrow batting third
today
there's a drive
high up there
off the monster
shorebird
comes into first base
over shot a bit first and third on a
drive by renfro is jd martinez 286 25
home runs he's driven in 88 big day
yesterday
up the middle
[Applause]
i'm not sure there is anything yarbrough
throws that surprises jd martinez he's
looking for it he knows exactly what he
wants and he got that pitch middle of
the plate didn't try to do too much with
it nice easy single up the middle here
we go the second with francisco mejia
batting a one
another trickler
sale throws off
that's an athlete for you and that's the
word that was a very athletic play
bouncing off the mound that quick with
the turnaround off balance throat two
down to rosarina
got him again
second time for a rosarena
and four for chris sale taylor motter is
over one he is grounded to the pitcher
one out one on 3-2
reaches out kisses that one that one's
headed back to the wall
off the wall margot couldn't make the
play here comes vasquez he's rounding
third he's going to score and he's going
to do it standing up
and the red sex lead to 2-1 that's
definitely what this young man needed
feels like the red sox are on the verge
of busting this one open on a red throw
base hit first time up the red throw
drives one to left field back by the
wall it's going to get up on the green
off the top of the wall here comes mater
to score throw into second and a pop-up
slide he's safe for the double schwarber
stopping at third it's 3-1 red sox and
they are all loaded up here the red sox
on the verge of really busting it open
rafael struck out first inning
and a base hit in the center field
schwarber underscore renfro will be held
as the throw comes into third base and
the sacks lead in four to one so bring
up bobby dalbeck who drew a walk in the
first inning
down the line
that's going to keep on bouncing renfro
will score martinez will score
deborah's held at third and the red sox
are piling on against yarbrough they now
lead it six to one bronco to second
luplow aboard it first another
right-handed hitter manuel margot
one two and a big swing and a miss he
struck him out two more k's in the
inning for chris
a base it away from getting right back
in this game got the right man at the
plate nelson cruz he knocked in the only
other run
sky back into center field for dugo
joseph the track and cannot make the
catch off his glove
cruise is going to go all the way to
third and the throw is high and he's
going to come around to score so walls
rosarina and franco all score and cruz
who was at third
with that throw high
circles them all a game in hand and this
happens
[Applause]
a little tapper third base side and
that's going to go as a paint set
they've had enough of those today last a
week
and here comes alex cora
here's margo he's the ninth minute in
the inning and he drills that one
verdugo on the run looping to make the
play
made a really nice catch middle of the
fourth seven to five red sox rose arena
will swing the bat fairly hard won't he
he doesn't get seated
in there caught up looking
well that was 97 one out here in the
sixth inning juan de franco's yet to be
retired
and a base hit to center there's another
one his fourth hit of the day
so after the triple in the first three
consecutive singles so here is luplow
with franco at second and then the timer
on diaz at first
[Music]
here comes franco in the score
and the reigns will admit it first and
third and they trim the deficit to only
one it's 7-6 on the base hit by luke
lowe tying run at third now manuel
margot right-handed hitting center
fielder
high chop picked off by denver's no play
at second goes to first and gets the out
and the red sox survived the inning with
the lead but it's down to one in the
middle of the sixth first and third in
front of hunter renfrow
live shot at basic
and the score is modern
little more breathing room now eight to
six
second rbi today for hunter here's jd
now another hot hitter 359 over the
previous eight games
and it's a ground ball second out there
franco across the bag the first
out there and the rays
get the double play first and third two
out one ball and one strike to bobby
dulbeck
ground ball
[Applause]
that's
shortstop
taking it the short way in a second
we're headed into the seven eight six
have a man in third two gone
gets the call with the top of the order
due
up that's up the middle base it into
center field
and the rays will get a run reaching out
to rosarita driving in the run to make
it 8-7 wander franco a triple and three
singles four for four
gonna be caught our ooze on a low line
drive will grab that
and that will retire the side and brings
up aroos who's gone over three tire
field is in the shade for the moment
there's a well-hit ball toward the red
sox bullpen way back and gone
over the red sox bullpen with a couple
of rows to spare
boy we have seen jonathan araus put a
charge into some baseballs lately it's
nine to seven red sox here in the
seventh inning adam and eve on the mound
and it's getting late cruz diaz wendell
do up for the race the one-two pitch
swinging a drive deep to left field look
out casket flagging it is gone
nelson cruz with home run number 28 and
he's cut the lead to 9-8 and out of eno
who had not given up a home run through
his first 58 games of this season has
now given up home runs in each of his
last two the rays have been chasing
since the second inning and now they're
down to the last three outs but here it
comes to meadows swinging a high drive
straight away center moving back for
dugo back to the track to the wall
off the top of the wall and karen's back
towards the infield meadows around
second he's going to try for third
lanoris is waving him he's on his way to
the plate and it's an inside the park
homer on for austin meadows and we're
all tied up austin meadows gets into it
gives it a charge
and not getting a whole lot of help is
alex ferdugo this is where you have to
have your corner outfielders coming over
to help you out
bouncer
rafael devers
got him
to the bottom of the ninth we go at
fenway socks nine tampa bay nine nelson
cruz for the rose arena still standing
at second base in the pitch swinging a
line drive underneath the glove of the
first baseman cordero and down the right
field line here comes a rosarina here's
the throw from renfro it's late cruz
flying in the second he is safe ray's
take the lead it's ten to nine and now
here's brandon loud a pitcher for yandy
diaz
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on another run jose iglesias just signed
today by the red sox
and a shot and a right field a base hit
now it's a one-run game
you never know so they're all filled up
and it's plawecki and not cordero now
the pitch
swinging a grounder torch short wander
charging he's got a hurry raceway
race win
race win an improbable comeback at one
time down 7-1 come into fenway on this
labor day and win it 11-10